Abracadabra, sprich jetzt Deutsch!
Juhu, jetzt spreche ich Deutsch.
Die Hallo Deutschschulebietet in Zürich
zentral gelegen qualitativ hochstehenden
Deutschunterricht.
Mit kompetenten Lehrer und Lehrerinnen
und modern ausgestatteten Kursräumen
bietet die Hallo Deutschschule
zeitgemässen Unterricht für Erwachsene
aller Herkuftsländer.
In der Hallo Deutschschule
sprechen wir viel und machen Spiele.
Das macht Spass und ist immer lustig.
So bleibt der Unterricht
abwechslungsreich undinteressant.
Wir haben immer viel zu lachen.
Unser Team besteht aus kompetenten
und motivierten Deutschlehrern,
die seit vielen Jahren Deutsch
unterrichten.
Gelernt wirdmit Hilfe von Videos sowie
audiovisuellen und interaktiven
Deutschübungen.
In der Klasse sind wir alle etwa gleich gut.
Das hilft mir beim Lernen und gibt mir
ein gutes Gefühl.
Bei Fragen kann ich auch andere
Lernende fragen und wirkönnen in
der Freizeit weiter zusammen lernen.
Als lizenziertes Telc-Prüfungs-Zentrum
bietet die Hallo Deutschschule
für die Wirtschaft wichtige Zertifikate an
und bereitet dieTeilnehmenden
professionell auf die Tests vor.
Wir wurden in der Hallo Deutschschule
sehr gut auf unsere Telc oder Goethe
Prüfungen vorbereitet.
Dadurch haben viele diePrüfungen
bestanden.
Das hilft uns bei der Arbeit!
Danke Hallo Deutschschule!
Wir Lehrer und Lehrerinnen
der Hallo Deutschschule unterrichten
schon seit vielen Jahren
und wissen die Antworten auf deine Fragen.
Es macht uns immer wieder Freude,
wenn wirunsere Klassenräume betreten,
weil auch wir immer viel aus allen
Kulturen lernen können.
Hast du grammatische Fragen?
Möchtest du deine Konversation
trainieren
und deinen Wortschatz verbessern?
Wir helfen Dir dabei, dass du in deinem
Niveau gute undnachhaltige Fortschritte
machst.
Lernende können auf unserer Homepage
kostenlosÜbungen, interaktive Deutsch
Lernspiele und deutsche
Aussprachetrainings herunterladen,
damitsie auch zu Hause oder
unterwegs lernen können.
Es hilft ihnen schnellere Fortschritte
zu machen,
mehr Worte zu kennen
und auch korrekt anzuwenden.
Wir organisieren allmonatlich einen
Ausflug, bei dem wir die Region Zürich
erkunden sowie des Öfteren
Film- und Fussballabende.
Nehmen Sie mit Ihren Klassenkameraden
an diesen Aktivitäten teil
und machen Sie Freunde!
Die Bücher der Hallo Deutschschule
zeigen viele spannende Themen,
auch über die Schweizund ihre
kulturellen Eigenheiten.
Die Bücher sind schön gemacht
und haben praktische Übungen für
Zuhause und in der Schule.
Bei der Hallo Deutschschulegibt es
tägliche Intensivkurse bereits ab 490
Franken pro Monat.
Semi Intensivkursesogar schon ab 270
Franken für fünf Wochen!
Wir an der Rezeption sprechen viele
Sprachen undkönnen dir sicher alles so
erklären, dass du es verstehst.
Bei Fragen sind wir für dich da.
Hallo Deutschule
Deutsch lernen mit Spass.
Buche jetzt deinen GratisEinstufungtest
und deine Probelektion!